I THINK THAT CAN YOU HEAR ME.
GREAT.
THE ASSEMBLY STEPPED UP BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE DEALING
WITH ISSUES OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE'RE GOING TO IT BEGAN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE SOME
MEMBERS BECAUSE OF OBVIOUSLY THE
CELEBRATION OF THE DAY. OF THAT
WILL NOT BE HERE FOR ANOTHER
TWENTY MINUTES BUT WE WANT TO
HOLD YOU ANY LONGER UNDERSTAND
SOME OF YOU.
ARE GOOD AN AVID READER AND RIP
THAT WE'VE BOTH STARTED TO
THIRTY AND THOUGH AND THAT
CHANGED A TO A JOURNEY I MEAN.
BASICALLY BEGINNING AT THE END
OF ADJOURNMENT OF THE. OF THE
FLOOR SESSION SO WE WANT TO
RESPECT YOUR TIME AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE AND BEGAN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY ITEMS THAT
WILL ACTUALLY BE VOTED ON TODAY
THEY'LL BE HOLD HELD OVER BUT
YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE COMMITTEES.
THE HEAR FROM THE STAFF AND YOU
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND AND MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
CONCERNING THOSE MATTERS. WE
HAVE TWELVE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY OF THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
AND SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN.
OUR SESSION O. IT AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE FIRST
GROUP WHAT ISSUE NUMBER ONE
DEALING WOULD RECEIVE A SHIPMENT
OVERVIEW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
ONLINE AND CLARK KELSO ON THE
RECEIVER IN CHARGE OF A MEDICAL
CARE IN CALIFORNIA'S PRISON
SYSTEM.
BY WAY OF AN OVERVIEW HOCKEY MY
COMMENTS BRIEF IN THE RESPOND
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
I JUST TELL YOU WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
IAN.
IN THE CASE OF SENSUALLY.
OR WE HAVE AND ALSO.
TODAY.
I'VE YOU ARE TAKE OR WHERE THIS
ON A PROCESS OF REVIEW IN
DELEGATION OF INDIVIDUAL
INSTITUTIONS FOR MANAGEMENT BACK
TO THE STATE.
I ES UP TODAY WE HAVE DELEGATED
I BELIEVE BY MY COUNT FIFTEEN
INSTITUTIONS.
I WOULD NOTE ON PAGE ONE OF THE
REPORT I IT HAS.
THE LAST SENTENCE OF THE FIRST
PARAGRAPH OF THE BACKGROUND HAS
SOME SOMEWHAT DATED INFORMATION.
INDICATING WE HAD DELEGATED TEN
AS OF JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
A BUT AS OF TODAY UP WERE UP TO
FIFTEEN.
I HAVE ALSO SCHEDULED.
DELEGATION MEET AND CONFERS
BEFORE I DELEGATE I'M REQUIRED
TO MEET WITH THE PARTIES.
I'M WE HAVE DELEGATED THOSE
ESSENTIALLY AT A RATE OF ABOUT
ONE. A MONTH A FEW MONTHS COMING
FORD WILL HAVE TO A MONTH.
ON THE SCHEDULE THEM FOR A
CONSIDERING DELEGATION OF THE
REMAINING PRISONS.
STRETCHES OUT UNTIL ABOUT
FEBRUARY OR MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
THE PROCESS THAT WILL
DELEGATION.
IN EVALUATING A DELEGATION IS
DATA INTENSIVE.
ON THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS TO COMPLETE ITS
REPORTS FOR AN INSTITUTION. I
RECEIVE A REPORT FROM THREE
COURT EXPERTS.
THE A PLAINTIFFS IN THE STATE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO A PROVIDE
INPUT. SO THERE'S A LOT THAT'S
GOING INTO EACH ONE OF THESE
DECISIONS.
I AFTER I DO A DELEGATION.
ESSENTIALLY THE.
IF THERE IS REASON TO REVOKE A
DELEGATE.
PLAINTIFFS COUNSEL MORE BRING
ABOUT THE TO MY ATTENTION.
I'M SO FAR WE HAVE HAD A KNOW
REPLICATIONS OF ANY DELEGATION.
I END THAT WE KNOW FOR MANY OF
THE. POST DELEGATION VISITS BY
THE PLANT THE PRISON LAW OFFICE.
THAT THAT WHAT THEY'RE SEEING
BASICALLY HILLS.
ARE A CONTINUATION.
OF OPERATIONS OR AN IMPROVEMENT
IN OPERATIONS.
SO WE WERE AT THIS POINT I'M
FAIRLY COMFORTABLE THAT THE
DECISIONS BUT I MAKING US TO
WHAT WHAT TO DELEGATE.
OUR THEY ARE SOLID DECISIONS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING
I MEAN FOR MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION STEADILY.
ON SECOND THING I THINK IS
USEFUL TO REPORT ON.
JUDGE HENDERSON WHO PRESIDED
OVER THE CASE
A FROM TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
UNTIL ON AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN.
HE HAS RETIRED FROM THE BENCH.
AND THE CASE IS NOW BEEN
ASSIGNED TO A DIFFERENT FEDERAL
JUDGE IN SAN FRANCISCO A JOHN
TIGER.
UP WHO IS TAKING A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO MANAGEMENT
OF THIS PART OF THE CASE.
I THINK THE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IS A JUDGE HENDERSON.
WOULD PROVIDE.
GARDENS
TO ME AND AT TIMES TO THE
PARTIES
BUT WOULD DO SO MOSTLY
INFORMALLY WITHOUT HAVING
HEARINGS AND MOTIONS.
AND THE OTHER RESULT.
THE CASE WAS.
.
IT MOVED FORWARD WITHOUT A
SOMETIMES THE BURDENS OF
LAWYERS.
IF I CAN SAY THAT HAS A LAW
PROFESSOR I GET A CHANCE TO SAY
THAT.
.
WHAT THE LAWYERS BEHIND ME I'M
SURE ARE BURNING IN THEIR EARS?
JUDGE TIGER HAS DECIDED THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A STATUS LIKE
FORMAL STATUS CONFERENCE IN HIS
COURT.
EVERY THREE MONTHS OR SO.
AND HE HAS REQUIRED THE PARTIES
TO MEET AND CONFER BEFORE THESE
HEARINGS AND PROVIDE A STATUS
REPORT.
AND ARE NO QUESTION THAT'S THAT
PROCESS THAT MORE FORMAL PROCESS
IS HELPING TO FOCUS.
THE PARTIES.
ON WHAT THEY AGREE IT NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO AND THE CASE.
AND TO IDENTIFY ANY AREAS OF
DISAGREEMENT.
.
AND I THINK THAT'S A POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE YOU KNOW TEN
YEARS AGO THE GOLF WOULD HAVE
BEEN HUGE.
BUT AT THIS POINT.
THERE ACTUALLYIS. SUBSTANTIAL
AGREEMENT AS TO WHAT NEEDS TO
FINISH.
AND THEN A FEW THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE DONE WHERE THE PARTIES
DISAGREE AND THE JUDGE AYE THERE
WILL. OUR RESOLVE THOSE THAT YES
THEY HAVE TO BE DONE ORIEL
DECIDE NO THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
DONE.
THEM BUT THOSE CASE MANAGEMENT
JOINT CASE MANAGEMENT
STATEMENTS.
PROVIDE RELIEF VERY USEFUL ROAD
MAP.
TO. THE CONCLUSION OF THE CASE.
AND I THINK I'LL STOP AT THAT
POINT AND SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS.
ANY OF IT.
A TESTIMONY.
THE QUESTIONS.
ONE OF THE QUESTION SO THE
UPDATE IS FIFTEEN PRESENCE THAT
HAVE BEEN DELEGATED BACK TO THE
STATE FOR CONTROL OF THE STATE.
ARE AND YOU'RE SAYING TO US THAT
YOU ANTICIPATE THAT THIS. THE
REMAINDER OF OF THE PRISONS WILL
BE THAT WILL HAPPEN FOR THEM BY
TWENTY. NINETEEN WE WE HAVE
SCHEDULED ON THE MEET AND CONFER
MEETINGS
OF TO THE END SO THAT'S THROUGH
THE SECOND OR THIRD MONTH TWENTY
NINETEEN. OUR I CAN'T TELL RIGHT
NOW HOW MANY OF THOSE WOULD BE
ACTUALLY DELEGATED.
BUT.
WE ARE TO POINT WHERE ANY I CAN
LOOK AT A CALENDAR AND SAY WE'RE
AT LEAST CONSIDERING DELEGATION
OF THE REMAINING PRISONS.
BY FEBRUARY OR MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN.
WHICH IS ON IMPROVEMENT FROM
WHERE WE WERE SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
OKAY.
OF ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS.
TURNING THIS.
OKAY HEARING THOUGH COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
REPORT.
THIS ITEM US OBVIOUSLY WILL BE
HELD OVER. TOUGH FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND VOTE.
WOULD AT THE ITEM NUMBER TWO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE RECEIVERS
LIKE ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
SYSTEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOING
READER AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OVER THE FISCAL MANAGEMENT
SECTION FOR CCGS SO BE SPEAKING
TO US SOME OF OUR PROPOSALS.
FIRST UP IS E. ADDRESS.
.
WE ARE A QUESTION EIGHT POINT
THREE MILLION AND TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY NINE TEAM.
AND THEN SEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION ONGOING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY. OF FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
LICENSURE WE OUT WE HAVE SOME
LICENSE LICENSURE DEFICIENCIES
IN THE CENTER SYSTEM.
WERE ALSO REQUESTING SOME FUNNY
FOR DISASTER RECOVERY.
WE HAVE SOME DICTATION SOFTWARE
AND SOME TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR EACH ADDRESS
IT'S BEEN ROLLED OUT ALL THIRTY
FIVE INSTITUTIONS SO IT'S COME
BEEN COMPLETELY ROLLED OUT AND
WE HAVE ALL OF OUR PATIENTS AND
THE SYSTEM. AND AS OF FEBRUARY
WE HAD DONE OVER NINE MILLION
TRANSACTIONS WITHIN THE CENTER
SYSTEM.
SO.
AIDS TO ADOPTION CONTINUES TO
GO WELL.
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
THE FINANCE BUTTON FINANCE.
BELIAU JONATHAN PETERS SOME OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO WE DO RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING INCREASES FOR
THE ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD
SYSTEM.
HOWEVER WE ALSO RECOMMEND BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO USE THE FUNDING
INTENDED TO PURCHASE THE
ADDITIONAL CONCURRENT USER
LICENSES THAT THE RECEIVER WAS
MENTIONING. AT A AS THEY ARE
NEEDED THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
RATHER THAN.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO ENSURE
THAT THE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IS REVERTED BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND RATHER THAN RETAIN IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS ANY MEMBER.
FROM OTHER COMMITTEE.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THIS MATTER.
IT'S FUN.
.
OKAY SO IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS AGREEMENT AMONG THE
DEPARTMENTS IS TO MODIFY THIS
PROPOSAL SO THAT BY PUT NINE
MILLION. IS FOR CC YOU LICENSE
PURCHASES ONLY. AND THAT ANY
UNSPENT MONEY WILL BE REVERTED
BACK THIS JOURNAL FUND IS THAT
CORRECT YES OKAY FIVE ONE MAKE
SURE THAT'S IN THE PUBLIC
RECORD.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT BOND AND THAT TAKES A
STATE THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD
OVER ALSO IN THE TEXAS ISSUE
NUMBER THREE WHICH OF THE
RECEIVER CAN. A CORRECTIONAL
CLINIC MODEL.
AND PHARMACEUTICALS.
OKAY SO WE BEFORE TO
CORRECTIONAL CLINIC MODEL BCP.
IN THIS WERE REQUESTING FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION AND TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN AND FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION ON GOING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO LEASE AUTOMATED.
DRUG DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
INCLUDING THE BCP IS WELL IS IS
SOME TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH OUR OF MID
DISTRIBUTION AREAS AS
CORRECTIONAL CLINICS.
THIS WILL BRING CCR TO
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE.
NARCOTICS STORAGE LAWS.
IT'LL HELP ELIMINATE
PHARMACEUTICAL WASTE WILL BOMB
FROM UNUSED MEDICATIONS. AND.
WILL HAVE ELECTRONIC RECORDS OF
THOSE NARCOTICS FROM ORDER TO
THAT DISTRIBUTION. AND.
IT'LL ALL OUR PILL DISTRIBUTION
AREAS TO BE LICENSED.
AND IN COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE REQUIREMENTS.
ANY ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE OR
ANY LA OAK FINANCE OKAY. OF ANY
MEMBERS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
INSERTING THIS PHARMACEUTICALS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT ITEM TO WILL BE HELD OVER
FOR LATER OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ITEM NUMBER FOUR DEALS WITH
JENNA TOLL SERVICES.
YES HOME.
AT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IN STOCKTON.
WE HAD DONE A TO B. C. P. TWO
YEARS AGO ON TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN. TO HIRE PRIDE TO
CONTRACT WITH PRIDE TO PROVIDE
JANITORIAL SERVICES.
AT AT THAT FACILITY.
AFTER THE THE PROPOSAL WAS
APPROVED.
SEIU CAME BACK AND SAID IT WAS
NOT COMPLIANCE WITH GOVERNMENT
CODE ONE NINE ONE THREE OO.
WHERE CIVIL SERVICE STAFF
SHOULD BE PERFORMING WORK THAT
CAN BE DONE BY CIVIL SERVICE
STAFF?
SO WE DEVELOPED A THREE YEAR
TRANSITIONAL PLAN WHEN THE
SECOND YOUR THAT TRANSITIONAL
PLAN WHICH IS CALLING FOR A BI
CP.
THAT WE WILL THEN BEGIN TO
TRANSITION FROM PRIDE THE CIVIL
SERVICE OVER THE IT THE BUDGET
YEAR AND WILL BE COMPLETELY
SOULS SERVICE.
JANITORIAL AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY NINETEEN IF APPROVED.
SOME UP AMOUNT YOU'RE RIGHT AT
THE.
ALL THE WORDS JANITORIAL
SERVICES THIS IS ACTUALLY QUITE
SPECIALIZED ARE CLEANING UP FOR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES RIGHT SO
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH THIS IS.
WHAT WHAT YOU MIGHT NORMALLY
THINK OF AS JANITORIAL FIRM FOR
EXAMPLE FRONT OFFICE BUILDING?
OKAY AND THAT'S WHY IT'S BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHALLENGE FOR US
TO UP TO GET THIS PART OF THE
CLEANING PROGRAM IN PLACE OKAY.
THEN A COMMENTS FROM.
ANY OF THE GROUPS OKAY ANY PUB
OUT ANY MEMBERS.
THE COMETS ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE WE HAVE ONE PUBLIC
COMMENT YES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I AM MARIA
PATTERSON. ON THE BARGAINING A
FIFTEEN CHAIR FOR STATE WORKERS.
ON.
AND THE CAPACITIVE CHAIR I
REPRESENT CUSTODIANS RESPONSIBLE
FOR CLEANING STATE BUILDINGS.
LIKE THIS ONE AT NIGHT WHEN
EVERYBODY GOES HOME GETS CLEAN
BY STATE EMPLOYEES.
I ALSO REPRESENT LAUNDRY
WORKERS.
SUPERVISING COOKS
AND FOOD SERVICE WORKERS AND
PRESENTS AND OTHER FACILITIES.
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
AND CITY SEE OUR ADMINISTRATION
FOR WORKING WITH THIS ISSUE IN
SUPPORTING STATE WORKERS.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW THE STATE
HAS BEEN CONTRACTED WITH PRIDE.
FOR CUSTODIAL SERVICES AT C.
EIGHT CF.
ARM
WE APPRECIATE.
THE EFFORT OF PRIDE WE BELIEVE A
STATE JOBS A BETTER WAY TO HELP
SOMEONE.
OBTAINED A SUBSTANTIAL CAREER.
AND A BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
WE ASK THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
APPROVE THERE AS THE REQUEST IN
THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU WHO WORKED
ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW COULD COULD
HAVE BEEN A VERY.
CONTENTIOUS SITUATION A AND I'M
REALLY PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
OUR STAFF IS WORK WITH OUR LABOR
GROUP TO MAKE SHOULD WE COME TO
A GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF THE.
WHO'S DOING THE WORK AND AND YOU
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT OF STATE
WORKERS GENERALLY HAVE MORE
STABILITY IN THEIR LIVES IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
AS WELL AS CAREER OPTIONS.
TERMS OF RETIREMENT IN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND AND CAN DO
THE JOB. AND THAT'S THE ALSO
EXTREME IMPORTANCE OF THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR MAKING MY LIFE
WONDERFUL. AND I THINK YOU I'M
HAVING OR FBI YOU CAN DOWN MY
DOOR SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT APPRECIATED AND THANKS TO
ALL WHO WORKED ON IT.
I WE WILL HOLD ITEM FOR OVER
FOUR.
GREAT CAN FOR MORE
CONSIDERATION OF WE DON'T THINK
A BILL OUT OF YOUR QUOTE NO GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A ROLE NOW FOR QUORUM WE WE NEED
THREE TO HAVE A FORM OF TRYING
TO WAIT ARE REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE
CAME. BUT THAT THAT WILL BE A
WHILE EVIDENTLY SO A WE WILL
CALL ROLE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WEBER HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE FORM. THAT
TEXAS ITEM NUMBER FIVE DOUBLE
EQUIPMENT.
YES SO WE'VE PUT FORWARD A.
BCP TO REQUEST FOR SOME DENTAL
EQUIPMENT FUNDING.
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE.
MUCH OF THE EQUIPMENT THAT IS
ONLINE IN THOSE DENTAL CLINICS
WAS DONE IN TWO THOUSAND SIX TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. AND SO ALL.
MUCH OF THE EQUIPMENT IS IS
GOING BEYOND USABLE LIFE.
WE HAVE HISTORICALLY REPLACED.
WHO WOULD WORK ON A A BREAK FIX
APPROACHED EQUIPMENT? AND IT'S
LED US TO HAVE TO DO SECTION SIX
WHO ARE TWENTY SIX IS TO REMOVE
FUNDING ARE REAL LIFE ANY FROM
OTHER PROGRAMS.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO ESTABLISH
A.
EQUIPMENT BASELINE.
IN ADDITION WHEN YOU KNOW DEL
EQUIPMENT BREAKS IT. EIGHT
CREATES A LOT OF DOWNTIME YOU.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF OTHER
OPTIONS.
TO PROVIDE CARE WHEN IT COMES
TO DENTAL YOU NEED THE TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY HAVE IN
THOSE CLINICS.
AND SO.
WE'D LIKE TO SECURE SOME FUNNY
TO CREATE A REPLACEMENT SCHEDULE
FOR SOME CRITICAL EQUIPMENT.
OKAY.
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE AMAZON
WORTH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH LA OVER
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION OKAY
RIGHT ALEJO. PAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR KITTEN O'NEILL ILIO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ESTIMATED THAT AS
A RESULT OF THIS PROPOSAL IT
WOULD SPEND ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS
ANNUALLY ON. EQUIPMENT REPAIR
GIVEN THAT THIS DENTAL EQUIPMENT
WOULD BE RELATIVELY NEWER UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL SO WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFY THE
PROPOSAL BY REDUCING THE COST
REQUESTED AMOUNT BY HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
SOUNDS GOOD EVERYONE IS IN
AGREEMENT ON THAT THAT'S
WONDERFUL AND.
YEAH BUT WITH A WONDERFUL.
ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY ANY COMMENT FROM THE
AUDIENCE PUBLIC COMMENT.
CURRENT WANT TO THANK YOU ALL TO
FOR WORKING TOGETHER MAKES A
LIFE A LOT EASIER WHEN WE AGREE
THAT THERE ARE SOME.
MODIFICATIONS THAT CAN BE MADE
IN THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WIT
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
O. DENTAL ORAL SURGERY YES WE.
SUPPORT AN ORAL SURGERY
PROPOSAL.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE HUGE
DEFICIENCY IN THE DAHLE BUDGET
IS DRIVEN BY ALSO FOR ALL
SURGERIES THESE ARE SURGERIES
THAT ARE ABOVE A NORMAL.
DENNIS
SCOPE OF WORK AND SO WE HAVE TO
CONTRACT FOR THESE MORE
DIFFICULT SURGERIES AND WERE WE
WOULD LIKE TO CREATE A BASELINE
FOR THAT. THOUGH SURGERIES AND
AND IT IS A CRITICAL NEED TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OKAY ANY COMMENTS
FROM FINANCE REALLY WELL NOW.
MEMBERS COMMENTS.
OKAY ANYONE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT ITEM WILL BE HELD OVER ALSO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WOULD NOT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS A MENTAL HEALTH BAD
MANAGEMENT.
SO.
HOME SO WE PUT TOGETHER A BCP UP
FOR THE HOPE THAT MANAGEMENT
THAT'S REQUESTING TWENTY POINT
ONE MILLION AND UNDER FIFTEEN
NINE POSITIONS.
IT'S BROKEN DOWN INTO SOME
SUBSECTIONS.
THE FIRST SECTION IS AN INMATE
REPORTING UNIT AND THE SEMI
REPORTING UNIT WILL.
PROVIDE SOMEBODY REALIZATION
OVERSIGHT AND.
HELP US COMPLY WITH IMPATIENT
TIMELINES.
THAT WE.
HAVE GOTTEN IN TROUBLE WITH BY
BY NOT MOVING OUR INMATES.
FAST ENOUGH TO THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF CARE.
WE ALSO HAVE THE HEALTH CARE
POPULATION UNIT WE CALL HIT POP
AND HIP POP.
REFERS THE PATIENTS TO THE
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF CARE AND
ENSURES THAT THERE IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE HOUSING AND WE NEED
SOME MORE DEDICATED STAFF FOR
THAT AREA AS WELL TO HELP
FACILITATE THOSE MOVEMENTS.
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO CREATE SIX
REFLECTS BIRDS THIRTY OF THOSE
WOULD BE AT CMF AND THIRTY WOULD
BE A SEAT STUFF AND PLEASE FLEX
BEDS WILL ALLOW US TO FLEX
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BIRDS. AND THEN ARE IMPATIENT
ACU AND INTERMEDIATE OF LEVELS
OF CARE. AND WE FEEL OF IT WOULD
GIVE US.
.
A WAY TO REACT TO SOME OF THE
SPIKES THAT WE'VE SEEN THE
SYSTEM SO OVER THE SUMMER MONTHS
REALLY SEE SPIKES IN ALL CRISIS
BIRDS. AND THEN WE SEE THE
INTERMEDIATE CARE IN THE ACUTE
CARE GO UP.
IN THE FALL MONTHS AND SO BY
ALLOWING US TO FLEX THESE BIRDS
IT WOULD ALLOW US TO BE MORE
AGILE TO THE POPULATION NEEDS SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO CREATE TO THOSE
UNITS WANT TO SEE HIM AFTER ONE
AT SEAT CF.
IN ADDITION.
WE'D LIKE TO CREATE TWENTY
UNLICENSED MOVEMENT HOPE CRISIS
BEDS AT CIW CALIFORNIA CITIES
ARE FOR WOMEN.
TO CREATE SOME ADDITIONAL
FEMALE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BEDS.
AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW WE
HAVE TWO FEMALE FACILITIES IN
THE SYSTEM. SO WE NEED TO BE
CREATIVE IN TRYING TO GET SOME
ADDITIONAL BEDS TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THAT
SCENE THE CRISIS BUT NEEDS FOR
FOR FEMALES INCREASES WHILE.
WE ALSO HAVE A HUGE GAP OF
MIDDLE HEALTH CRISIS BEDS IN THE
SOUTHERN REGION.
OF THE STATE.
AND IN ORDER TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THAT NEED IN A COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
DOWN AN UNLICENSED UNIT AS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO AND TRANSFER THOUGH
THAT TWENTY BED UNIT DOWN TO
RICHARD J. DONOVAN CHO A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN THE
SOUTH.
TO CREATE SOME ADDITIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS BEDS DOWN
THERE IN TOW WE CAN HOPEFULLY
GET A FEW OF OUR OTHER
PROPOSALS.
MOVING.
AND THEN FINALLY WE'RE ASKING
FOR. SOME POSITIONS FOR OFFICE
OF RESEARCH
RIGHT NOW OF THE COURTS HAVE.
DIRECTED US
OR ORDERED US TO WORK WITH
MCMANUS CONSULTING GROUP TO
PROVIDE OUR MENTAL HEALTH
PROJECTIONS.
WE'D LIKE TO BRING THAT BACK
UNDER THE HOUSE OF CDC ARE.
WE HAVE TO PROVE THAT WE CAN
MANAGE THESE PROJECTIONS WE ALSO
FEEL THAT THE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
HAS SOME. EXPERTISE IN THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF CUSTODY.
AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO
GIVE US.
MORE SOLID MENTAL HEALTH
PROJECTIONS BUT ALSO BRING IT
BACK UNDER THE VEIL OF CDC ARE.
IN IN HOPES OF ENDING THIS COURT
CASE AND AND MOVING OUT FROM
UNDER THE FEDERAL COURTS OKAY.
MY COMMENTS WERE FINANCE AMAZON
WORTH PART OF FINANCE AGAIN.
I ALSO I WOULD HAVE A LITTLE
BIT TO THE PROJECTION.
COMMENT.
.
SO IT DOESN'T HURT TO KNOW THE
HIPAA DOES A LOT OF THE
PROJECTIONS NOW WITH MCMANUS
PROVIDING THE OVERSIGHT.
AND SO IT'S KIND OF HARD TO
COMPARE THE COST OF THAT
CONTRACT. FOR WITH MCMANUS TO
THE COST OF THE RESOURCES FOR
OFFICE OF RESEARCH BECAUSE HIP
HOP IS ALREADY DOING A LOT OF
THE WORK.
SO.
NO THROUGH PUZZLES NOT ONLY TO
TRANSITION OVER TO THE OFFICE OF
RESEARCH ALSO TO FREE UP SOME A
PIC POTS RESOURCES OF THE CAN
FOCUS MORE ON THE. PATIENT
MONITORING IT THAT MOVEMENT AS
WELL. SO I THINK IF WE WERE
PROPOSING TO MOVE IT TO THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE ANOTHER REQUEST
HIGHER RESOURCES FOR.
THE KID MANAGE THEIR WORKLOAD
EFFICIENTLY OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FELLOW
JONATHAN PETERSON WITH THE LA
SHOW AS THE DEPARTMENT INDICATED
THIS ITEM INCLUDES VARIOUS
PROPOSALS WE MADE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON SOME ASPECTS
OF THE. THE GOVERNOR'S VARIOUS
PROPOSALS.
FIRST WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED LIMITED
TERM FUNDING AS OPPOSED TO
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE FLEX
BEDS.
THESE BEDS WOULD BE STAFFED IN A
WAY THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO BE.
.
TO SERVE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BED PATIENTS.
BASED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
CURRENT PROJECTIONS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BEDS THAT AND THAT
NEED APPEARS TO BE TEMPORARY.
SWEEPING PROVIDING FUNDING ON AN
LIMITED FOR YOUR LIMITED TERM
BASIS WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT
TO ADDRESS THIS NEED.
SECOND WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH STAFF.
TO TAKE OVER THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROJECTIONS WE'RE AWARE OF ANY
PARTICULAR.
.
INACCURACIES ARE PROBLEMS WITH
THE CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH
PROJECTIONS THAT JUSTIFY THE
EIGHT TIMES AS MUCH COSTS FOR
CDC ARE TO TAKE OVER THESE
PROJECTIONS.
THIRD AND FINALLY WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
FUNDING FOR THE ARE YOU AND HIT
POP STAFF THAT THE DEPARTMENT
MENTIONED.
BECAUSE THESE COULD HELP.
MOVE PATIENTS INAPPROPRIATE
TREATMENT FASTER AND REDUCE THE
NEED FOR.
MET MENTAL HEALTH BEDS NOT IN
THE FUTURE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS.
OKAY OF.
OF.
OKAY NICK ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
OKAY.
THIS QUESTION OBVIOUSLY IS
RELATED TO OBVIOUSLY ITEMS EVEN
NINE AS WELL SO WE'RE GOING TO.
HERE THAT AND THEN ALL THIS
WILL KIND OF FIT TOGETHER WITH
REGARDS TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
BATES IN THE CAPACITY IN OUR
ASSESSMENT. OF WHAT WE MEET SO
THAT TAKE ITEMS EIGHT AND NINE.
RIGHT NOW TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY
ALSO COMPLEMENT NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN DEALING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH THREATS. AND OTHER THE
VARIOUS OF. MIDDLE HAVE BE IT'S
CRISIS IN FACILITIES AND AND HOW
WE FUNDED AND WHAT WHAT PASSED
THE LOOKS LIKE.
OKAY.
THIS ITEM EIGHT AND I THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN THE
FIFTY BAD MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
FACILITY AND THE DAY JOB OF THE
RICHARD JONATHAN'S CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY IN THE SAN DIEGO AREA.
OTHER FIFTY MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BE IT'S THE OF SODAS THOSE BIT
SO UP YES. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DEAN BORG
REPRESENTING THE FACILITY
PLANNING CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
DIVISION FOR CDC ARE. THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT INCLUDED
FUNDING TO BEGIN THE DESIGN
PROCESS FOR TWO BUILDINGS AS
YOU'VE MENTIONED AT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. THAT CAN
PROVIDE LICENSE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AT THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS INTERMEDIATE OR CUTE CARE
LEVEL OF CARE. A PROPOSAL BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE DESIGN
PHASE FOR THESE TWO BUILDINGS.
THE PRIMARY IMPETUS BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT CCR DOES NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT LICENSE BED
CAPACITY TO MEET THE CURRENT
PROJECTED INPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT NEEDS. SO SO
THE COMBINATION OF ACUTE
INPATIENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IS ALL CARED FOR IN A
LICENSE DOES IN ANY LICENSE
CARE.
ARE CURRENTLY IN ORDER TO MEET
THAT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR
LICENSE BED AND THAT BAD
TREATMENT NEED WE OPERATE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR UNLICENSED A
MENTAL HEALTH BEDS. THERE ONLY A
WE CAN ONLY OPERATE THEM BASED
ON WAIVERS FROM THE FEDERAL
COURT.
AS LONG AS THE SYSTEM DEPENDS
UPON COURT GRANTED WAIVERS TO
PROVIDE A PORTION OF OUR
CAPACITY.
IT IT WILL NOT BE REALISTIC FOR
THE STATE TO BE IN A POSITION TO
END COURT SUPERVISION.
EQUITIES ANALYSIS INCLUDED A
CHART PROVIDED BY THE LA OWE A
WHICH FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON THE
PROJECTED NEEDS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BEDS.
WE BELIEVE AS I'VE MENTIONED
THAT THE LICENSE BUT NEEDS TO BE
VIEWED AS A CONTINUUM ACROSS THE
THREE LEVELS AND A PROVIDED.
THE A COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
ILLEGAL WITH A CHART THAT SHOWS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PROJECTED OVERALL BUT NEEDS FOR
THOSE THREE LEVELS AND THE
EXISTING CAPACITY. AND AS.
WAS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY THESE
TWO PRESENTS ARE LOCATED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE US A SEVERE DEFICIT
OF.
CRISIS BEDS AND OTHER TYPES OF
MENTAL HEALTH LICENSE TREATMENT
BEDS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW.
CATHARINE KEEP ROCKER DIPPY
DIRECT FROM AND HEALTH PROGRAMS
IS HERE.
TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT THE
NEED FOR THESE BEDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE CATHERINE TO
BROCK DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THAT
STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM
AT CDC ARE.
OCCURRED I THINK A COUPLE OF
THINGS ARE IMPORTANT FOR AYE
THIS GROUP TO NO ONE IS THAT
WE'VE BEEN LABORING UNDER A
SERIES OF COURT ACTIONS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
YEAR.
MARCH AND APRIL ORDERS.
THAT CONCERN THE DELAY AND
MOVEMENT OF PATIENTS TO IN
PATIENT HOUSING AS WELL AS THE
SUFFICIENCY. OF.
.
OF THOSE NUMBERS.
AND THE DELAY IN MOVEMENT IS
INEXTRICABLY INTERTWINED WITH
OUR ABILITY TO WITH A SUFFICIENT
NUMBER INSUFFICIENT NUMBER. UP
BECAUSE.
WE NEED TO MOVE PEOPLE OUT IN
ORDER TO MOVE THE MEN'S SUIT
ENDS UP BEING A BIT OF A DOMINO.
UP WHAT WE'RE SUGGESTING HERE IS
REALLY.
TAKING IT A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO HOW WE MANAGE THESE
BEDS.
THROUGH THE THE UP PROPOSAL
THAT YOU PROVED LAST YEAR UP FOR
THAT FLEX BAD FOR TAKING THAT
SAME CONCEPT HERE.
AND APPROACH THE IDEA IS TO BE
ABLE TO FLEX
I WITH THE DYNAMIC NEEDS OF THE
POPULATION. THOUGHT THE
POPULATION'S NEEDS FLEX PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE COURSE OF
EACH YEAR WE NOTE IN THE. WINTER
FALL WINTER MONTHS THE NEED FOR
CRISIS BAD TENDS TO BUY DIP I
AND IN THE SUMMER MONTHS IT
TENDS TO INCREASE.
AND SO WERE TRYING TO IDENTIFY
A WAY TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THOSE SPIKES IN NEED AND THIS IS
ONE WAY OUT THAT WE CAN THINK TO
ADEQUATELY. ABOUT RESPOND TO
THOSE FLEXING NEEDS.
.
WE DO HAVE CURRENT WEIGHTLESS
FOR A HOT CRISIS BED MOVEMENT.
I SHOULD ACTUALLY TAKE ME I'M
SORRY I SHOULD GO BACK AND
REFLECT FOR A MOMENT ABOUT THE
TODD THE ORDERS THAT WE
RECEIVED.
THE ORDERS REQUIRE OUT STRICT
ADHERENCE TO TIME LINES AND HAVE
THREATENED.
.
A SANCTION MONETARY SANCTION FOR
ABOUT MISSING THOSE TIME LINES.
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH CRISIS
BET WAIT LESS.
MANY OF THOSE.
PATIENTS WAIT.
.
MUCH LONGER THAN IS APPROPRIATE.
AND WE'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT.
BUT.
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BEDS.
AND WE.
CAN'T ALLOW CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THOSE FIVE PATIENTS TO SIT IN.
IN APPROPRIATE SETTINGS WAITING
FOR THE RIGHT THAT.
.
THIS GUIDE THIS PROPOSAL THOUGH
DOES RETURN US TO.
DOES ALLOW US TO MOVE PEOPLE
MORE QUICKLY WE HAVE A.
A GREAT NEED IN THE SOUTHERN
PART OF THE STATE BY THE
MAJORITY OF OUR BEDS HOWEVER IN
THE NORTHERN PART THE STATE.
SO THIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS US TO
RESPOND. MORE QUICKLY OUGHT TO
THOSE NEEDS BY GETTING THEM
QUICKER INTO OF BEDS LOOK
PROXIMATE TO THEIR.
HOME INSTITUTION.
YEAH.
IT COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
BELIAU.
JONATHAN PETERSON LA SO WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE WORKING DRAWINGS
FUNDING FOR THE TO MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS PET PROJECTS AS THE
CURRENT PROJECTIONS SUGGEST.
THAT THE ADDITIONAL BEDS WOULD
NOT BE NECESSARY BY THE TIME THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS COULD BE
COMPLETED.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
THESE ADDITIONAL BEDS ARE NEEDED
TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BEDS AND REPLACE UNLICENSED
MENTALHEALTH CRISIS BEDS BASED
ON THE CURRENT PROJECTIONS.
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BEDS APPEARS TO BE
MANAGEABLE WITH THE SIXTY FLEX
BEDS THAT WE HAD JUST TALKED
ABOUT A PREVIOUS ITEM.
IN TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO WANTS TO USE
THESE PADS TO ADDRESS BROADER.
.
PROPER BROADER UNLICENSED BED
ISSUES.
WE WOULD JUST KNOW THAT. TO THE
EXTENT THE PROJECTIONS ARE IN
THAT ARE EITHER OVERESTIMATE THE
NEED WE COULD BE IN A POSITION
WHERE WE MAY HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE UNLICENSED BEDS ANYWAY.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE I NEED
FOR THESE BEDS IS.
OVERESTIMATED WE MIGHT BE IN A
POSITION WHERE THE CONSTRUCTION
IS NOT NECESSARY SO DEPENDS ON
WHICH.
THE DIFFERENT WAYS IN DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES IN WHICH THESE
PROPOSALS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
ONE OF MR LACKEY AROUND SEVEN
EIGHT AND NINE.
ANY COMMENTS ON THE PUBLIC.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO THAT
I MEAN THERE BAY BASICALLY WE'RE
BEING TOLD THAT BY THE TIME THE
CONSTRUCTION OCCURS. THAT
THEY'LL BE NO NEED FOR THE
SPIRITS.
SO WE'D BE BUILDING SOMETHING A
HUNDRED BITS I GUESS.
.
THAT IN TIME WOULD NOT BE NEED.
BASED ON YOUR PROJECTIONS OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO LOOK LIKE
I'M THE LEADER IS A CHARLIE
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE AT A
SHOW THAT WE'VE YOU REVIEW THOSE
NUMBERS. DIFFERENTLY SO BASED
UPON THE CAPACITY OF THE BEDS WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW THEY PROJECTED
NEEDS FOR ALL LEVELS OF CARE NOT
JUST MY HOPE CRISIS BAD BUT FOR
ALL THOSE LICENSE LEVELS OF CARE
WILL STILL EXCEED OUR CAPACITY
GOING FORWARD AND WE WOULD NEED
TO CONTINUE TO USE.
UNLOCK UNLICENSED BANDS.
AND THAT'S BASED ON THE CURRENT
THE CURRENT PROJECTIONS SHOWING
AB DECREASE IN THE MIDDLE OF
POPULATION OVERALL. THAT'S BASED
ON THE FIRST SET A POPULATION
PROTECTIONS TO INCORPORATE A
HOME
PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
OBVIOUSLY MORE TIME IS
NECESSARY TO TRULY SEE WHAT OF
TREND LINE IS FROM THE LOOK FROM
THOSE PROJECTIONS MY.
THE THE FLEX BUT.
THE FLEX BEDS WERE MENTIONED
EARLIER.
BITE VIEWING IT ACROSS ALL
THREE LEVELS OF CARE ELIMINATES
WHETHER THAT SIXTY BEDS IN THE
CRISIS BY CATEGORY THE ICF
CATEGORY BECAUSE WE'RE SIMPLY
SAYING FOR ALL THE BEDS
AVAILABLE FOR LICENSE CARE. WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH AND FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE BASED UPON
OUR PROJECTIONS WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE USING UNLICENSED BEDS.
AND FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
LOOKING TO A DAY WHEN THE STATE.
AS DICK MANY ACTIONS BUT LOOKING
TO A DAY WHEN THE STATE CAN GET
OUT OF COURT SUPERVISION.
NOT HAVING. THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE CARE BASED ON YOUR OWN
PROJECTIONS.
IS IT DIFFICULT PART TO US START
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE COURT.
OKAY SENT IT.
OKAY UP.
I THINK.
ONE MORE POINT.
YOU NEED TO GO TO THE MIKE THANK
YOU SORRY OTHER ONE MORE POINT
WORTH MENTIONING.
WE HAVE A COURT ORDER TO RUN THE
LICENSE BEDS.
SO THE COURTS ARE ALLOWING US TO
RUN THOSE LICENSE BEDS AND SO.
IN ORDER TO SEE
WE NEED THAT COURT ORDER TO KEEP
USING THEM SO WE NEED THESE
LICENSE BUT TO REPLACE THOSE ON
LICENSE BIRDS. OTHERWISE THE
COURTS ARE ALLOWING US TO
CONTINUE SO IF WE WANT TO GET
AWAY FROM THE COURTS WE WE NEED
TO TO GET SOME LICENSE BEDS IN
THE SOUTH ESPECIALLY.
I WE CURRENTLY TRANSPORTING
PEOPLE TO BE SPIRITS.
BETTER THAT WE DON'T HAVE NOW I
MEAN IN TERMS OF NEW YEAR'S GIFT
AT SOME BETS. THERE SO WHERE
BASICALLY TRANSPORTING
INDIVIDUALS THERE THAT YEAH BUT
THE SHORT VERSION IS THAT WE ARE
MOVINGPEOPLE FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOMETIMES ALL THE WAY
UP THE STATE. IN ORDER TO GET
THEM INTO A CRISIS SPED UP THE
TIME IT TAKES.
.
TO MOVE THEM AND THAT THE TRAVEL
ITSELF IS DISRUPTIVE TO THE
PATIENTS HAD TO THEIR CARE
GNAWED IT IS.
CERTAINLY CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE
TO UP KEEP THE UP PATIENTS
PROXIMATE TO THEIR UP HOME
INSTITUTION AND MINIMIZE THAT
TRAVEL.
WE'VE ENDEAVOR TO DO THAT TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN AT THIS
PROPOSAL GETS US PART AWAY THERE
BUT IT IS NOT A PERMANENT FIX.
THE PERMANENT SOLUTION IS THOSE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL BATS.
OKAY OKAY IT IN ADDITION WE HAVE
FOURTEEN MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
BEDS RGD AND WE HAVE TWELVE IT
CIW WHICH IS AN ALL FEMALE
FACILITY.
SO LET'S GET TWENTY SIX BEDS IN
THE IN THE SOUTHERN REGION.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MIGHT THERE IS
ALSO A PROPOSAL FROM THE
PREVIOUS ITEM THAT INCLUDES
MOVING TWENTY BEDS ALBEIT
UNLICENSED BIRDS REMOVED FROM A
SACRAMENTO DOWN TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SEVEN OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
WHEN I'M I'M DONE WITH OTHER
FINANCE AGAIN.
I THINK WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
FOR THE BEDS WE THINK THEY ARE
NECESSARY TO SHOW THE COURT THAT
WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS SO THAT
WE EVENTUALLY WHEN. YOU KNOW WE
ARE NOT UNDER COVER OF COCOA
COURT OVERSIGHT WE WILL HAVE THE
NECESSARY LICENSE FADS.
TO IT YOU KNOW HOPE OUR
PATIENTS I THINK ALSO MENTAL
HEALTH PROJECTIONS ARE HARD.
IT'S HARD TO PROJECT WHAT OUR
POPULATION IS GOING TO DO
ESPECIALLY FIVE YEARS OUT. AND
IT'S HOT IT'S.
EASIER BUT SEE IT'S EASIER TO
USE
HARDER TO RESTART A COP OUT LEE
PROJECT.
AND I THAN IT IS TO.
JUST LIKE STARTED AND WE A FEW
MORE YEARS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE WITH
THIS PROPOSAL.
ALSO I'M SURE.
SOMEWHERE IN THE SYSTEM IF
CAPACITY REALLY SHOWS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A NEED ANYMORE I'M
SURE THERE ARE OTHER BEDS IN THE
NORTH THAT WE CAN.
ISN'T DE COMMISSIONER WE CAN I
KNOW WE CAN TAKE DOWN YEAH WE
CAN TAKE DOWN VETS IN THE
NORTH'S THAT WE HAVE AN OFFENSE
IN THE SOUTH.
OKAY AND BY TAKING DOWNLOAD BE
SHIFTING THEM FROM A MENTAL
HEALTH PURPOSE TO A MEDICAL
PURPOSE BECAUSE OFTEN IN A
BUILDING THAT SHARES BOTH OF
THOSE PROGRAMS OKAY.
HOW MUCH IS THAT BUT PRIVATE PAY
THIS FAR IN FINES AS A RESULT OF
THIS COURT ORDER DO WE HAVE ANY
IDEA? YEAH I CAN ADDRESS THAT.
AT THIS POINT THE COURT HAS IN
FACT NOT OF LEVY THOSE FINDS OUT
SHE HAS THREATENED THEM AND.
THE ORDER FROM MARCH OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REQUIRED THAT WE COME
INTO COMPLIANCE BY MAY FIFTEENTH
OF TWENTY SIX PASSED SEVENTEEN.
I UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE AT THAT TIME.
AND OUR ESTIMATE TO DATE IS
THAT WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
FINES.
BUILT.
IN TODAY WAITING OTHER REASON
SHE HAS NOT YET PULL THE TRIGGER
ON ANY ACTUAL.
ORDER ON THE FINES IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE.
.
APPEALED THAT WATER.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
BRIEFING PROCESS NOW AND IT
WHILE THERE'S NO STAY ON THE
ORDER ITSELF.
SHE HAS NOT LEVY DEFINES I
THINK IS A FUNCTION OF THE US
APPEAL. OKAY SOUNDS GOOD
CURRENT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
COVERS ITEM SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE
AND THEY WILL ALSO BE HELD OPEN.
UP FOR ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION
IF THERE IS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED TO GET
PLEASE LET US HAVE INFORMATION
CONCERNING THE NEEDS FOR THOSE
PETS. WHAT ITEM NUMBER TEN?
WHICH IS A MEDICAL DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENTS FACE TO.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED OR RENOVATED AT MOST
CDC OUR PRESENCE OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS AS PART OF OUR HEALTH
CARE RELATED CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN ONGOING.
THESE FACILITIES RANGE FROM
ROOMS ADJACENT TO MEDICAL
CLINICS WHERE MEDICATIONS ARE
PREPARED AND DISTRIBUTED TO ALL
THE INMATES HOUSE ON A GIVEN
PRISON YARD THAT ARE SERVED BY
THE CLINIC. BUT ALSO INCLUDES
ROOMS WITHIN HOUSING UNITS AT
HOW SPECIALIZED.
POPULATIONS OWN ADMINISTRATIVE
SEGREGATION HOUSING UNIT THE
INMATES ARE PROVIDED THEIR
MEDICATIONS AT THE SELF FRONT.
OR AN ENHANCED NO PATIENT
PROGRAMMABLE HEALTH UNIT WHERE
THEY ARE PROVIDED THEIR
MEDICATIONS AND WINDOWS HAD BEEN
CONSTRUCTED IN THE DAY ROOM.
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE REQUESTS
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION TO BEGIN A DESIGN FOR A
FACE TO OF THESE MEDICATION.
DISTRIBUTION IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS.
AND THIS WOULD AFFECT ABOUT
FOURTEEN PRISONS.
THERE ARE THREE GENERAL REASONS
WHY A PROJECT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS.
IN THE SPACE TO A PROJECT.
FOUR EIGHT OF THESE PRISONS.
MEDICATION CORPORATION ROOMS AT
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION UNITS
WERE ERRONEOUSLY OMITTED FROM
PHASE ONE OF THE PROGRAM THEY
WERE JUST THEY WERE DISMISSED SO
THIS IS DOING THE SAME THING AT
THOSE EIGHT PRISONS. THAT OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION UNITS
I HAVE HAD CONSTRUCTED.
AT SIX PRISON CDC ARE HAS
EXPANDED THE ENHANCED AL PATIENT
PROGRAM MIDDLE HEALTH PROGRAM.
AT THOSE PRISONS INTO
ADDITIONAL A HOUSING UNITS SO WE
WOULD.
BE REQUESTING THEM FUNDING TO
BUILD MEDICATION JUST REFER
OPENSIN THOSE HOUSING UNITS.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE ARE
PRISON FACILITIES THAT
PREVIOUSLY HELD A SEGREGATED
POPULATION SUCH ISSUE OR
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION THAT
NOW HAS BEEN CONVERTED TO
GENERAL POPULATION AND SO THOSE
PRISON YARDS LACK THE WINDOWS
FACING THE YARD.
TO PROVIDE MEDICATIONS OF THOSE
INMATES INSANE NOW NO LONGER
HAVE TO REQUIRE SERVICES IN
THEIR HOUSING UNIT BUT CAN BE
OUT ON THE ARE THEMSELVES.
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES THERE WOULD BE
DESIGNED FOR THIS PROPOSAL ARE
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE MEDICAL
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED IN THE
RECEIVER'S TURNAROUND PLAN OF
ACTION.
AND AS IDENTIFIED THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION HAS BEEN
REQUESTED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THE LA OVER GUARDING THE
POPULATIONS ALL BE SERVED BY
THESE IMPROVEMENTS.
WELL THIS ITEM IS BEING PLACED
ON HOLD WE PLEDGED CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THAT BOTH ENTITIES
TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION IN
ADDRESSING THE ADDITIONAL
CONCERN.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
THE LEO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
AS THE DEPARTMENT MENTIONED IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
THESE PROJECTS WE DID REQUEST
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
WOULD OUTLINE.
HOW MANY INMATES COULD BE SERVED
WITH THE PHASE ONE PROJECTS THAT
ARE ALREADY UNDER CONSTRUCTION
AND HOW MANY AND WHAT TYPES OF
INMATES COULD BE SERVED WITH
THOSE PROJECTS? WITH THAT
INFORMATION THE LEGISLATURE WILL
BE IN A BETTER POSITION TO
EVALUATE WHETHER ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE NEEDED TO SERVE.
THE POPULATION AS IT'S PROJECTED
TO CHANGE OVER TIME
SO PINNING RECEIPT OF THAT
INFORMATION A WE RECOMMEND WITH
HOLDING ACTION ON THIS ITEM.
SPECIFIC TO THE PROPOSAL'S
MENTION THAT CONVERT DIDN'T
EXCUSE ME
CHIU SECURITY HOUSING UNITS INTO
GENERAL POPULATION UNITS WE
RECOMMEND DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT REVISED
PROPOSAL SPECIFIC TO THOSE. I
REQUEST AS THOSE APPEAR
NECESSARY EVEN WET ONCE WE GET
THE INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY.
MEMBERS.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC.
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHEN THAT
THE INFORMATION WILL BE
FORTHCOMING WITH THE GUYS WHAT
ELIOT WAS REQUESTING IN TERMS
OF.
HOW MANY PERSONS WOULD BE SERVED
BY PHASE ONE OF THE PROJECT?
I I THINK THAT.
EARLY TO MID APRIL WILL BE ABLE
TO MEET AND TALK ABOUT IT A PART
OF THE ISSUE IS THAT THEY.
THE BILL IF YOU TO SERVE ISN'T
NECESSARILY QUANTIFIED BY NUMBER
OF PEOPLE.
IN ALL CASES SO IT'S MORE A
QUESTION OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
POPULATIONS IN THE NEED.
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS SO IT'S AYE
IF IT WAS.
SIMPLE NUMBERS I HAVE IT IN
THEIR HANDS ALREADY.
BUT WE'RE WORKING ON IT AND AND
BY EARLY APRIL I THINK WE'LL BE
ABLE TO GET SOMETHING WE SHOULD
HAVE THAT BEFORE MAY REVISE
ABSOLUTELY ALRIGHT SOUNDS GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WOULD NOT
ITEM ELEVEN.
WITH THE HELP ACCESS VEHICLES
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR A
NUMBER.
.
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN INVOLVES.
REQUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
APARTMENT FOR SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FINDING. AYE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. TO REPLACE
SEVERAL.
.
HIGH PRIORITY HEALTHCARE ACCESS
VEHICLES.
MOST OF WHICH ARE REPLACEMENT
OF EXISTING VEHICLES AND THEN.
HAVE FORTY SEVEN ADDITIONAL
VEHICLES WERE PROPOSING TO ADD
TO OUR FLEET.
.
AS IS MENTIONED IN FINANCES A
PAGES IN ADDITION TO THIS
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING WITH CITIES YES
CURRENTLY TO ADDRESS OUR FLEET
NEEDS MORE GLOBALLY. BUT PAT THE
DEPARTMENT IDENTIFIED THIS AS
THE BAY AREA MOST IN NEED ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY SO THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO ADDRESS RIGHT
NOW. I'M JOINED BY DEVIN FONG
WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OUR OFFICE OF BUSINESS SERVICES
HIS CAN PROVIDE YOU JUST A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL ON THEM WILL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
PICTURE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
.
SO ON OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE.
THE RECEIVER DELEGATED
AUTHORITY OR RESPONSIBILITY FOR
FLEET OVERSIGHT MANAGEMENT TO
CDC ARE SO WE'VE BEEN OVER
SAYING.
HEALTHCARE ACCESS VEHICLES EVER
SINCE THAT TIME.
SO THIS AS JASON JASON MENTIONED
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST FOURTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION. IN
REPLACEMENTS TWO POINT NINE
MILLION FOR ADDITIONAL ASSETS
IDENTIFIED. IN THE RECEIVER'S
OPERATIONS MONITORING AUDITS.
SO WHAT WERE.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO WITH
WHAT THIS FUNDING IS REPLACE?
THE HEALTHCARE ACCESS VEHICLES
IN GREATEST NEED OF REPLACEMENT
ONE GREATEST NEED IF IF YOU
WILL.
SO AS PART OF THAT IS WE WOULD
HAVE TO CREATE A FLEA
ACQUISITION PLAN.
PERSONAL TO STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL UPDATED
APPROVED BY DE JUST SO THAT WE
CAN BEGIN PROCUREMENTS.
PART OF WHAT WE'RE DOING.
INTERNALLY AS WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE ABILITY TO REDIRECT OR
REPLACE.
VEHICLES.
THAT COULD BE REPURPOSE THAT
ARE NON EIGHT CA ESOS PART OF
THAT ANALYSIS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT.
CURRENTLY IS
BASICALLY THREE THINGS THIS
ISN'T AN UPGRADE RIGHT SO WE
HAVE TO DO A LOT ABOUT REACH.
THIS IS THE VEHICLE IN BETTER
CONDITION.
TO ACTUALLY MOVE IT DOESN'T
MEET OPERATIONAL NEED WILL WE.
.
CAN WE PERFORM THE SAME TYPES OF
DUTIES WITH THIS OTHER TYPE OF
VEHICLE AND WILL DE JUST APPROVE
IT AS A DISSIMILAR ASSETS SO
THAT'S. YOU KNOW ANOTHER FACTOR
TO KEEP IN MIND AND IS A COST
EFFECTIVE DO WE HAVE TO PROVIDE.
SECURITY MODIFICATIONS ON OR DO
WE HAVE TO HAVE IT REMOVED SIR
THE QUITE A BIT OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE THINGS.
AND AS WE DEVELOP THE FLEET
ACQUISITION PLAN WE'RE COMMITTED
TO DOING THAT AS WELL.
COULD.
SO.
THEN THE NEXT PART WOULD BE
DEVELOPED THE FLEET OPPOSITION
PROCESS AND THAT WE WOULD.
PLAN.
AND THEY WILL WORK WITH AND
COLLABORATE WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS THE RECEIVERS
OFFICE AND.
TDC ARE ADULT INSTITUTIONS
DIVISIONS TO SEE IF THE THINGS
MAKE SENSE PRESENT THOSE TO THE
UNDERSECRETARIES AND THAT
ULTIMATELY PRESENT THE FLEET
ACQUISITION PLAN TO BEGIN
PROCUREMENTS TO. TGS.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
BELIAU.
WELL WE DON'T RAISE CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL TO PURCHASE
NEW VEHICLES HOWEVER WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO REPORT
ON THE EXTENT TO WHICH IT COULD.
REPURPOSE OTHER TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE VEHICLES THAT ARE
PROPOSED FOR REPLACEMENT.
TO THE RATHER THAN DISPOSING OF
THEM ARE AUCTIONING THEM AND WE.
WE APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING INTO THIS POSSIBILITY
HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT ARE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO RIP IT REPORT.
WHEN THE INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE.
WHETHER IT WILL INDEED BE ABLE
TO REPURPOSE ANY OF THOSE
VEHICLES SOUNDS REASONABLE OKAY.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER CAUSE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
HE COMES FROM THE PUBLIC.
SO WE ASSUME THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ELIAS'S CONCERN AND THAT WE'LL
HEAR FROM. A.
HEAR FROM YOU WOULD REGARDING
THAT WE'RE TO RE PURPOSING THOSE
ITEMS OR HOW MUCH CAN OR CANNOT
BE USED BEFORE WE DO WHATEVER.
WE CAN DO WITH THEM. WE'VE HEARD
IT SEVERAL TIMES NOW YEAH OKAY
SOUNDS LIKE A PLAN SO WILL YOU
THAT BEFORE THEY MAY REVISE. OUR
LAST AND FINAL ITEM IS A VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
UNITS CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS
AND.
.
OKAY OKAY.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS HIGH IN
BUDGET YEAR HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
AFTER.
TO.
INSTALL AND MONITOR.
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM WITHIN OUR
CSP SACRAMENTO.
FACILITY AND MATT MENTAL HEALTH
UNIT SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS
PROPOSAL I'M JOINED BY MISTER
REST NICHOLS WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF OUR.
ENTERPRISE INFORMATION SYSTEMS
OFFICE EYES GREW WIDE YOU LITTLE
MORE DETAIL ON THEM WILL ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH
THE DRAMATIC INCREASES IN
TECHNOLOGY CAPABILITIES AND
REDUCTIONS IN COST LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED VIDEO RECORDING
SYSTEMS. HELPED INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESSES AND SO THE AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES
TRANSPARENCY OF ALL OF THE ACT.
ACTIVITIES THAT GO ON.
WITH THAT IN MIND ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO WE STARTED A PILOT
EFFORT TO TWO OF OUR PRISONS
HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON UP IN
SUSANVILLE CCW AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
THOSE IMPLEMENTATIONS WILL BE
COMPLETED THIS SPRING WE'VE ALSO
ENGAGE UC IRVINE TO HELP US
QUANTIFY.
THE IMPACTS OF THOSE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS
THIS PROPOSAL THOUGH IS IS ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE SCOPE IN THE
INTENT OF THE THE PILOT
IMPLEMENTATIONS.
SPECIFICALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE COLEMAN SPECIAL
MASTER.
ISSUED SOME SOME INFORMATION TO
ASK SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO SEE
SP SACRAMENTO AND THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ALLEGATIONS.
STAFF AND SOME OTHER INMATES.
RELATED TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
POPULATION AT CSP SACRAMENTO.
SO IT'S OUR INTENT TO BRING IN A
VIDEO SO.
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM THAT CAN
HELP TO EITHER QUALIFY OR REBUT
THE OUT THE SECURE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF ALLOCATE.
ALLEGATIONS AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING NOT ONLY THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES BUT
PROTECTING OUR AT RISK
POPULATION THE MENTAL HEALTH.
FACILITIES THAT SACRAMENTO.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
ANY COMES FROM LA FROM FINANCE.
I MEAN I WORK PART OF FINANCES
ONE ANOTHER AT THIS PROPOSAL IS
SPECIFIC TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
UNITS AT SAC IN ISN'T DIRECTLY.
TIED TO A RELATED TO THE
STATEWIDE.
PILOT THAT I HE MENTION OF IT IS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE COLEMAN ASPECTS
MONSTER MONITORING TEAM MUKA.
NEW HELLO YES THE. AND THE
EVALUATION OF THE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM ON THE ONE
YARD AT HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON
THAT'S BEING EVALUATED BY.
RESEARCHERS AT UC IRVINE AYE IT
IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
ARE LOOKING INTO ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST STAFF.
BY INMATES
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITH HOLD ACTION ON
THIS PROPOSAL INTEL THAT REPORT
IS AVAILABLE AND WE RECOMMEND
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE THAT REPORT BEFORE THE
MAY REVISE. AND IN ADDITION TO
REPORT ON THEIR IN THE MEANTIME
ON OTHER ACT.
STRATEGIES IT'S DEVELOPING TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT SACK
OKAY SOUNDS GOOD.
ALRIGHT ANY COMMENTS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS.
OKAY.
OF.
DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE OF THAT I
MEAN I KNOW WE DID THE THE PILOT
WITH THE.
HIGH DESERT AND ALL THAT.
AND THE RESULTS ARE NOT OUT YET
I'M UNDERSTANDING ARE THEY
AVAILABLE THE THEY ARE NOT
AVAILABLE YET THE FINAL REPORT
IS DUE TO US ARE RIGHT AT MAY
FIRST.
SOBRE CLOSED THE MAY REVISE.
WE WE HAVE SEEN SOME INITIAL
RESULTS
BUT WHAT THE UC IRVINE
RESEARCHERS ARE LOOKING AT
REALLY IS DIFFERENT THEN THEN
THE SITUATION THAT EXISTS WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION.
THAT THE ALLEGATIONS INCLUDE
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE WHICH IS
SIMILAR TO HIGH DESERT BUT WITH
HOLDING THE FOOD AND A LOT OF
OTHER TREATMENT. THAT THE UC
IRVINE REPORT REALLY WON'T
ADDRESS AND THIS IS OP A.
POPULATION THAT'S AT RISK AND WE
BELIEVE THE VIDEO SYSTEM CAN
HELP MAKE SURE THAT WHERE WE ARE
DEALING WITH THOSE ALLEGATIONS
AND PROVIDING APPROPRIATE
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY TO THAT
MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION.
WHAT IS WHAT IT WOULD IS THAT
WHAT OF THE VIDEOS WITH THE HIGH
DESERT GROUP DOING?
AND NOT LOOKING AT SOME OF THOSE
THINGS WHAT ARE THEY LOOKING AT
SO THEY'RE LOOKING AT YOU
SUPPORTS INCIDENTS ARE A LOT OF
ANY SORT OF VIOLENCE.
THAT GOES ON TO SEE IF WE CAN
CAPTURE THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE WE ARE.
SHORTENING THE LENGTH OF
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WE CAN.
SUBSTANTIATE
CLAIMS OR OR CHARGES AGAINST THE
APPROPRIATE OFFENDER.
AS AN EXAMPLE OFTENTIMES OF TWO
INMATES ARE TO FIGHT BUT NOBODY
SEES THAT THEY'RE BOTH CHARGED
HE COULD ACTUALLY BE AN ASSAULT
WHERE ONE INMATE IS A VICTIM. SO
UC IRVINE IS FOCUSED MORE ON
THAT SIDE OF THE THE EQUATION
AND LOOKING AT THE COST BENEFIT.
ENSURING THAT THERE IS A RETURN
ON INVESTMENT IN INSTALLING THE
SYSTEM.
AT SACK WE'RE REALLY DEALING
WITH THE CARE AND APPROPRIATE
SERVICES TO MENTAL HEALTH
INMATES THEIR VERY MUCH AT RISK
IN THE ALLEGATIONS IN THE NATURE
OF THE ALLEGATIONS THE
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER THERE. MAKES
IT A DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT THAN.
THE BROADER ISSUES THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AT A HIGH DESERT AND
A CCW OUT. THE OTHER PIECE THAT
CCW UP THE HIGH DESERT IS WERE
REALLY LOOKING AT THE TECHNOLOGY
COMPONENTS HOW BEST TO USE THAT
THE POLICIES OF WHO CAN LOOK AT
VIDEO.
HOW LONG IS THE VIDEO RETAINED
AND THINGS ALONG THOSE LINES SO
THERE'S A A MUCH BROADER
TECHNOLOGICAL IMPACT A?
AND STUDY GOING ON WITH THOSE
TWO PRISONS.
THAT DEAL WITH.
THEY POPULATION WEALTHY ON JUST
MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT.
OKAY  WELL I THINK THE
INFORMATION WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
US TO HAVE.
IN TERMS OF THE REPORT. IF
WE'RE BUYING EIGHT EQUIPMENT I
SOON. WOULD WOULD BASICALLY BY
THE SAME TYPE OF EQUIPMENT EVEN
THOUGH THE ANALYSIS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IN THE VIDEO
MAY BE DIFFERENT.
BUT.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD CHANGE THAT
MUCH IN TERMS OF NUMBER WHAT ONE
SEES IN THAT ROOM AND I THINK
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO SEE IF
THERE'S.
IF IT IS ACTUALLY WORKING OF THE
TECHNOLOGY IS IS A IS EFFECTIVE
IN IN. AND MONITORING WHAT WE
THINK WE SHOULD BE MONITORING
WHAT WE END UP WITH THE RESULTS
OF.
DENIAL OF FOOD OR VIEWS OR
SOMETHING ELSE I MEAN VIDEOS
VIDEO UP CLEARLY AT WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR MAY CHANGE BUT. I
ASSUME THAT THE IMAGES WILL NOT
CHANGE IN TERMS OF HOW WE.
ATTEMPT TO MONITOR LEASE
FACILITIES I ASSUME THAT'S
CORRECT NO MA'AM THERE. WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING FROM HIGH DOESN'T
SEE SYRUPY AFT WITH CAMERA
PLACEMENT HOME ARE HOW THE
RECORDINGS ARE ACCESS TELLING
THEIR RETAIN ALL OF THAT WOULD
BE ROLLED INTO THIS? SYSTEM AT
CSP SACK THIS ONE WOULD BE
PHYSICALLY SMALLER IT'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE CAMERAS
VERSUS A FULL IMPLEMENTATION AT
A LOCATION LIKE SACRAMENTO WOULD
BE CLOSER TO FIVE OR SIX
HUNDRED.
SO IT'S JUST THE MENTAL HEALTH
AREAS MOMENT THE PS YUGIOH P.
TYPE AREAS AND FOR ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IT YOU KNOW I'M A REAL BIG
STICKLER ABOUT DOE A STUDENT
PILOTS AND AND THEN BEFORE WE
FIND OUT WHAT THE PILOT SAID AS
WE IMPLEMENT SUPPLEMENTALS?
AND THOUGH I THINK PILOTS HAVE.
A VALUE IN TEACHING US IN
HELPING US TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS APPS LA AS WELL AS BE
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND NOT
OVER DOING SOMETHING WHEN. THE
PILOT BUT IT TOOK GIVEN TO SOME
OF THE INFORMATION SO I THINK
THE PURPOSE OF A PILOT IS ALWAYS
TO LEARN I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT
WE'LL GET
THAT INFORMATION
FOR ME. IF I MAKING ONE MORE
COMMENT WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
LEARNING SOME OF THOSE LESSONS
ALL GOODY WITH HIGH DESERT WE
WILL QUALIFY THOSE WITH UC
IRVINE WE'RE ACTUALLY EXPANDING
THE THE. A NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT
WE COLLECT AS WE'RE MOVING INTO
CCW HAPPEN THE REST OF HIGH
DESERT. THE SITUATION WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH INMATES AT SAC IS
JUST MUCH MORE URGENT MA THAT
CONTINUITY OF CARE THAT SPECIAL.
TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT THAT EXISTS
IN A PS YOU AND A. S. YOU AT
SAC.
THERE IS AN URGENCY THERE TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE ACTUALLY
PROTECTING THOSE THOSE INMATES
AND PROVIDING THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT'S NECESSARY FOR OTHER FOLKS
TO VALIDATE THE.
CENTER FOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM. THE MEMBERS.
IT COMES FROM THE PUBLIC.
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF OF
BEING EFFICIENT AND MOVING FORCE
FORWARD RATHER QUICKLY.
AND THAT COVERS THE TWELVE
ITEMS THAT WE HAVE FOR TODAY ALL
THOSE ITEMS WILL BE ROLLED OVER.
AND UNDER AND LEFT OPEN FOR.
VOTING WHEN WE GET AROUND TO
VOTING AT THAT TIME ITEMS HAT
WE'VE SAID WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION ON OR ILLEGAL HAS
SAID WE SHOULD HAVE THAT. I I AM
OPTIMISTIC WE WILL GET THAT
BEFORE WE HAVE TO MAKE A FINAL
DECISION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU THANK YOU MAY MEETING
IS ADJOURNED